what's happening reject nation Greg Alba
here and I'm foggy Nelson I hope you
guys watch her venom spoiler talk video
it was a fun video to film this is the
fourth daredevil trailer recovering I
was at the gym when this trailer dropped
wearing this shirt and I was like well
before I shower throw this shirt in the
wash
got to cover this other daredevil
trailer I don't I got to keep the
tradition going here I've got to just
always wear this in case they meet agent
point Dexter which is Poindexter that's
bullseye oh I guess they're confirming
this officially all right which is
awesome to hear mode somebody gets my
theory stands correct true search paying
off I'm not really I don't really know
much about he's not in the born-again
call make sure they'll be borrowing in
here there and everywhere we did that
want to say again thank you so much to
everyone sincerely who's been joining us
on our patreon page guys loving it
loving it over there over there we do
weekly Q&A is as well as TV show
reactions for many of shows that
includes my hero academia Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood and attack on
Titan as well as Riverdale Gotham and
supernatural and I don't know I mean we
might do this show I don't know this big
maybe but anyway there will definitely
be a review of the series up let's get
into this Jay talk to me about the
ambush this isn't the first time you've
used lethal force calling me hero
Oh federal government
FBI help keep me on the straight and
narrow okay drowning in deep water
understand
you found someone to kill me
I'm gonna spend all season waiting for
that shirt and that daredevil versus
daredevil I got legit chills during a
couple of those moments oh that's that
image is so born-again right there with
Karen page holding daredevil in her arms
and stained glass behind them man love
it what's neat about this I like I said
I don't know anything about bull's-eyes
backstory really but from what I can
tell he's filling the role that will
Simpson played it's Sim City plays in
the born-again comic-book Simpson is
actually in the Jessica Jones show he's
the one who starts dating Trish in the
first season who takes the pills who
makes Trish's Ark in the second season
so amazing with that drug yeah in the
comic book born-again he's a crazy ass
war vet really buff it's very different
than the Jessica Jones portrayal
he's like insane and it's similar to
what's going on here he becomes the
ultimate assassin that kingpin hires
from a military background who's a
little bit crazy and he uses him to try
to hunt down daredevil so they're taking
a couple elements and throwing it into
one the Simpson who who goes by nuke in
the comic nuke does not pose as
daredevil there they get some like
insane mental asylum guy whatever to
pose as daredevil
a way to lure out Matt Murdock but nuke
is a separate character and now that
seems like they're combining both
elements far away from the comic book
but giving it to bullseye in this which
is neat you know and also in the day and
age of like daredevil has done a lot of
course correcting for daredevil and just
the whole world like they
course-corrected daredevil but they
course-corrected the Punisher the
jumping-off point for that and I really
like that we've waited till the third
season to get bullseye again because
everyone's been wanting bullseye to come
in
people speculated they might come in in
season two I don't know what the general
perception is now of Colin Farrell's
portrayal which looks the exact same to
how the jigsaw in the Punisher war zone
movie is just the same as the one inside
of the Punisher show whatever area and
that's how this season is probably gonna
go is you know like bull's eye he's
gonna become Irish and put on the bull's
eye spin-off series you know just like
Punishers every season of daredevil is
going to be punctuated with like a war
yeah PTSD series every season of
daredevil is dedicated to course
correcting something that would the
other things that now we're that existed
in the same world I mean just from the
little glimpses we're getting I mean
this trailer is all focused on his
character and I mean I was pulled in
even though you don't get a lot of
prolonged moments I mean his performance
looks like it's gonna be pretty gripping
I like some of the points he's made yeah
like I feel like you know that's kind of
territory that we're getting into more
frequently now is like if I had a mask
on people call me a hero and stuff like
that I don't know what the behind the
scenes are in terms of what writers work
on what and what producers work on what
I don't really follow that side of TV
news but I I'm kind of wondering you
know how so much of the Punisher show
you know how that dealt so much with
PTSD in war vets and it kind of seems
like it's going down a similar path with
bullseye in this season and I don't know
if they're gonna be kind of introducing
some similar elements to that because
this guy's looking for a purpose now -
yeah and I like that we're gonna get
time to explore him because I mean go
back to Colin Farrell for a second it
seems like a lot of people have thought
his performance is a joke but I kind of
thought at the time when he came out
that everyone thought he was one of the
few good things about that movie but oh
yeah now looking back on it I feel like
every one time I hear someone bring him
up they talk about how it was just a
silly thing I imagine it's probably one
of those things where that movie hasn't
aged well and he's just one of the
better parts of it but that might not be
saying much yeah yeah and I mean this is
almost weirdly I kind of got like a
departed vibe for a minute there cuz
like it's not like a psych eval he's in
at the front like all I could think of
is my hand never shakes
studies yeah yeah it's like he's such a
crank like his whole thing is like he
never misses right yeah yeah well I
think this is a perfect way to introduce
bullseye and keep the comic lore going
because like I said it's it's borrowing
elements in the morning in comic and
then throwing it all to the bull's eye
world I'm sure if it was actual bull's
eye origins involved or feel free to
educate guys because I really don't know
oftentimes people worry about getting it
to fill in overload and having yeah
three style but this doesn't register
that way to me at all it's like yeah
it's another villain to talk about we've
already got in kingpin kingpins
established but in terms of like kingpin
versus daredevil usually daredevil needs
to be injured in order for kingpin to
actually beat him in a fist fight yeah
especially in this world I know there
was the big final fight in daredevil
season one where they're going at it was
an intense fight but it's also like
Matt's gonna win yeah I mean he's the
smaller guys yeah faster you know he's
trained in a different way Wilson Fisk
is just like a giant five-year-old yes
like beats on people you know like
kingpins gonna be used to destroy the
whole life around Matt Murdock in there
but to have bullseye in here he's gonna
be used to actually you know the front
trying to kill and mess with his mind to
to come face to face with your effigies
like such a weird thing I would imagine
for Matt Murdock to have your visit
perverted for the city you know and to
clarify I'm not a hundred percent sure
if his bed I get the impression his
background has some type of PTSD Ward
thing because he starts off in the
trailer saying the FBI helped keep me on
a straight and narrow path I don't know
if he had like some serial killer
tendencies or something and being in the
FBI did that but I like the approach of
this guy's an FBI agent he gets in
trouble for using lethal force you know
they had that no ambush sequencer he's
like killing people and whatever it
looks like he's trying to take down
kingpin in the beginning of this trailer
and any fails to do so could be one of
those things where it's like you got
real close
you got real close yeah that's what it
seems like to me when kingpin notices
his talent and skill so him feeling like
he doesn't belong to the FBI and then
kingpins sort of stepping in and helping
corrupt that brain even more it's kind
of a cool concept as opposed to taking
just traumatized war vet throwing him in
here I like this approach of a dude
who's working within the system is
technically a good guy cuz it's for the
FBI but you know he clearly has these
tendencies that are very dangerous and
lethal and now Honi and all that and
making him cross more into the dark side
yeah he clearly needs that little push
yeah you know and I get a psychological
vibe of some kind because you've got
that motif of the repeating voice that
do it Dex
yeah it Dex that like nagging voice yeah
the back of his head tax so I gotta
imagine that's gonna figure in somehow
you know he doesn't look all put
together in a lot of he's just himself
and the other thing too is he looks
amazing and I'm at I'm daredevil yeah I
don't know how they cast these things
but that's got to be a concern cuz like
the lower half of his face is that mask
like actually looked cool yeah it does
look cool good for him it does look cool
and I guess my last thing is if it's
also borrowing a little more just
additional inspiration from the comics I
imagine that the way they get the suit
because you know they have Melvin Potter
as a reoccurring role in season 1 and
season 2 so I imagine that there's
another threat maybe maybe gets Betsy
one more time yeah way to force him to
make a suit so that way Bowles I could
rock that bad boy but yeah I just can't
wait I just can't wait super like I want
I like the variety of the Marvel Netflix
shows but there's nothing like there's
nothing like they're all right guys well
how excited are you for this and please
if there's more information that you
want to provide about bullseye leave it
in the comments man I like to learn like
to learn you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation please click that
notification bell because you know
subscribe buttons don't do the trick as
much as they used to anymore and also
check us on patreon TV show reactions q
and A's would love to have you become a
patron Jake today